Whatcha gonna do with all that junk, all that
junk in outer space?
Hey space junkies, Julian here for DNews.
Space is more accessible than ever, and we’re
launching new stuff up there all the time.
But along with all the satellites and space
stations, we’ve also left a lot of litter
in our wake.
And if it hits anything, it’ll create more
junk and quickly get out of control.
To help keep track of all that junk, NASA
monitors the bigger pieces and actually publishes
a newsletter called Orbital Debris Quarterly.
That’s right, NASA talks about space junk
as much as we talk about gentlemen.
It’s like a tabloid for space geeks.
It even ranks the top 10 satellite breakups
of all time.
But why just keep track of it?
Why don’t we go out there and take out the
trash?
There have been some proposals and experiments.
As far back as 1996 the space station Mir
attached pieces of gel to the outside to gather
microscopic space junk, though the results
were negligible, ruling it out as trash collection
service.
Other ideas have been suggested, like launching
other satellites to grapple onto derelict
ones and hauling them back down to earth like
a professional wrestler doing a Batista bomb.
The Swiss EPFL’s CleanSpace One was drawn
up to grab Switzerland’s first satellite
Swiss Cube and remove it from orbit.
How do you like that, they send one tiny cube
up and they still want to clean it up, way
to go The Swiss.
But their solution can’t capture debris
that’s very large or very small.
But the ESA is also working on something to
take large satellites down by 2021, but like
the Swiss space roomba, it’s a one shot
deal.
In 2014 Japan’s space agency actually tested
out a metal space net designed to create a
magnetic pull to drag floaty bits out of orbit.
They hope to have something ready by 2019.
Ideas that don’t require sending something
expensive into space expensively have also
been dreamed up.
In 2012 Raytheon tested phase one of their
Space Debris Elimination concept.
The idea was a device suspended by balloons
80 km up would shoot a jet of atmosphere as
high as 600 km.
When junk hits the suddenly thick air, it
loses speed and comes back down to earth.
Raytheon concluded that while the energy costs
were high, they weren’t unreasonable and
could possibly be reduced with further development.
And of course, there’s everybody’s favorite
idea: space lasers.
Yes, space lasers.
Sure we could put them on other satellites
to give them a clear path, but that’s a
space law no-no because now you’ve started
weaponizing space.
Even putting them somewhere neutral like the
ISS is dicey because that’s how you get
rogue supervillain astronauts.
Instead if we’re going to have what NASA
boringly calls a “laser broom,” it would
have to be stationed on Earth.
This means you’d have to target fast moving
tiny particles hundreds of kilometers away
and pepper them with laser bursts in just
the right way to unsettle their orbit and
bring them tumbling down.
No easy feat.
Plus it is imperative that the laser doesn’t
miss and damage something we actually need
that’s farther out in space because the
laser beam just kept going!
Makes you wonder what happened to all those
shots that missed when X-wings and Tie Fighters
tangled.
Now, technically, we don’t have to do ANY
of this.
All objects circling the earth will experience
orbit decay and eventually crash into the
earth on their own.
Given enough time, space WILL clean itself.
But it’d be nice to have some control over
where all that heavy debris lands, and not
to have to wait decades or even centuries
for gravity to decide.
Right now the cost and challenge of cleaning
up space isn’t really worth the effort:
space is still a pretty big place and the
odds of collisions are slim.
But if satellites do start colliding, then
space junk will multiply and the problem will
get out of hand fast.
If it gets to that point, hopefully one of
these technologies will be ready to clear
a path and hopefully it won’t be the “laser
broom”.
So say we make these technologies to knock
space junk back down towards earth.
Then what?
Trace and Amy talk about dropping spaceballs
here.
What proposal is your favorite?
It’s lasers isn’t it?
ISN’T IT?